Ryan started going blind when he was 18, so it's been a long time now that he can't see. And one night he flies to Chicago for this work thing. And gets to his hotel room and he wants to call his wife back home in Canada to let her know that he's arrived safely. So all he needs to do is find the phone.
瑞安在18岁时开始失明，所以他已经很长一段时间看不见了。一天晚上，他为了工作飞往芝加哥。到了酒店房间后，他想给远在加拿大的妻子打个电话，告诉她自己平安到达。所以他只需要找到电话就行了。
And so I walk into the room and I find the bed. And then to the left of the bed, I feel along and I find this nightstand, which is where I expect the phone to be. And so I feel up the nightstand and there's no phone. Fine.
我走进房间，找到了床。然后摸向床的左侧，找到了我以为放电话的床头柜。我摸了摸床头柜，上面没有电话。好吧。
So I reach across the bed to the other side and find the other nightstand. And I feel that one up, and there's no phone.
于是我伸长手臂越过床，摸向另一侧，找到了另一个床头柜。我又摸了摸那个，也没有电话。
That's unusual, right?
这很不寻常，对吧？
It's a bit odd, right?
有点奇怪，对吧？
So Ryan can shuffle cautiously around till his knees graze into things. And that's how he finds a sofa. Which orients him.
瑞安可以小心翼翼地挪动，直到膝盖碰到东西。他就是这样找到了沙发。这帮他确定了方位。
And so I turn to where I think there might be a table, and poof! There's a coffee table. So I grope this coffee table for a while and there's no phone on it.
于是我转向我以为有桌子的地方，砰！有个咖啡桌。我摸索了半天，上面也没电话。
Grope is kind of a funny word to use for this.
用“摸索”这个词来形容这件事挺有意思的。
It sort of feels that way, though. You're just sort of-- because you don't know where anything begins or ends, so you really maul it.
不过感觉确实如此。你只是……因为你不知道东西从哪里开始又在哪里结束，所以你真的是在乱摸。
He says that as he moves around any new place, he doesn't exactly draw a map in his head. He says that it's more like wandering around in a first-person video game. One where nothing is visible until he touches it. So he figures OK, let's see what is on the other side of this coffee table that he's found. And he edges forward in the room.
他说，当他在新地方走动时，他并不会在脑海里画地图。他说这更像是在玩第一人称电子游戏。一个除非摸到否则什么都看不见的游戏。所以他想，好吧，看看他找到的这个咖啡桌后面有什么。于是他在房间里向前挪动。
And I find there's a desk. And I'm like, aha, the desk! So I feel around on the desk and there's a lamp and there's the notepad I'll never use, and there's stuff, but there's no phone.
我发现了一张书桌。我心想，啊哈，书桌！于是我在书桌上摸了摸，上面有盏台灯，还有我永远不会用的记事本，还有别的东西，但就是没有电话。
So I'm left to my last blind guy resort, which is I go back to the beginning. Back to the bed and I find the wall. And I start Marcel Marceauing the walls. I'm wiping them up and down.
所以我只能使出盲人的最后一招，那就是回到起点。回到床边，找到墙。我开始像马塞尔·马索那样顺着墙摸。我上下摸索着墙壁。
And I round the fourth corner and I get to the bathroom, and I go past the bathroom and there's nothing. And I feel behind me again and the bed is back behind me again. So I've circled this room.
我转过第四个角落，到了浴室，我走过浴室，什么都没有。我又向身后摸了摸，床又在后面了。所以我把这个房间绕了一圈。
And I even thought, well maybe it's a super fancy hotel. And maybe there's a phone in the bathroom. And I go in there and there's nothing.
我甚至想，也许这是家超豪华酒店。也许浴室里有电话。我走进去，结果什么都没有。
So I circle the room two more times this way, wiping it down. And I check the coffee table again. I check the desk again. And I just figure, forget it. I'll just go to bed and try again tomorrow.
所以我用这种方法又绕了两圈，把墙都摸了一遍。我又检查了一次咖啡桌。我又检查了一次书桌。我就想，算了。我还是睡觉吧，明天再试。
So he goes to bed. Doesn't call his wife. Sleeps.
于是他上床睡觉了。没给妻子打电话。睡着了。
And in the morning, he wakes up to the sound of something curious. A phone ringing. And groggy, he follows the sound, and finds somehow now, there is a phone in this room.
第二天早上，他被一种奇怪的声音吵醒了。电话铃声。他迷迷糊糊地顺着声音走去，发现房间里居然真的有一部电话了。
And the phone is on a coffee table. Now I know I felt that thing up to an illicit degree. I mauled that coffee table, and there was nothing on that table last night.
电话就在咖啡桌上。我明明记得昨晚把那东西摸得一清二楚。我把那张咖啡桌摸了个遍，昨晚上面什么都没有。
And so I answer the phone and it's my wife. And she says, "why didn't you call me last night?" And I said, "well there was no phone. But there is now."
于是我接起电话，是我妻子。她说：“你昨晚为什么不给我打电话？”我说：“好吧，昨晚没电话。但现在有了。”
She doesn't believe him that there was no phone, but this is kind of par for the course when you're married to a blind guy.
她不相信昨晚没有电话，但当你和一个盲人结婚时，这种情况见怪不怪了。
And so we talk. And then I hang up the phone and I go to get back into bed, and there's now a wall there.
我们聊了一会儿。挂断电话后，我准备回床上睡觉，结果那里现在多了一堵墙。
A wall. Where the bed should be is now a wall. He feels for the sofa. The sofa's right where it should be.
一堵墙。本该是床的地方现在成了一堵墙。他摸了摸沙发。沙发还在它该在的位置。
The wall behind the sofa is right where it should be, right there in place. He feels along the sofa again, inches towards where the bed should be, and yes, it's still a wall.
沙发后面的墙也在它该在的位置。他又顺着沙发摸过去，向本该是床的地方挪动，没错，还是堵墙。
And I'm totally disoriented at this point. Like it's funny and it's also sort of terrifying. Because I know the bed was there, and now there's a wall.
我当时完全糊涂了。这既好笑又有点恐怖。因为我知道床就在那儿，可现在变成了一堵墙。
And I keep touching the wall, thinking maybe this time it'll go away. And I go to the left, and there's another wall now. And I'm a grown man and I'm lost in a hotel room.
我不停地摸那堵墙，想着也许这一次它会消失。我向左走，现在又出现了另一堵墙。我已经是个成年人了，却在酒店房间里迷了路。
So what's your next move? What do you do?
那你下一步怎么做？你打算怎么办？
I ended up doing the Marcel Marceau thing. I start wiping the walls, feeling my way along the edges, and it wraps back around till I find the bed is actually behind me.
我最后又用了马塞尔·马索那一招。我开始顺着墙摸，摸着边缘走，最后又绕了回来，发现床其实就在我身后。
He was in a part of the room that he hadn't encountered the night before. This was an alcove on a side of the bed that he just never discovered.
他当时身处房间里他前一天晚上没接触过的部分。这是一个他从未发现的床侧凹室。
So here's what the room actually looked like. There are two coffee tables and two sofas on the left and the right side of the bed.
实际上房间的样子是这样的。床的左右两侧各有一张咖啡桌和一张沙发。
The mistake that he made the night before was this. When he was Marcel Marceauing the walls, he got 3/4 of the way around the room and got to the last wall. And he didn't actually feel all the way along that wall until it met another wall.
他前一天晚上犯的错误是这样的。当他像马塞尔·马索那样摸墙时，他绕了房间四分之三的路程，到了最后一堵墙。但他并没有沿着那堵墙一直摸到它与另一堵墙交汇。
Basically, he went a little ways down that wall, felt that the bed was behind him. So when he realized that the bed was behind him, be figured he was done. He stopped feeling that wall.
基本上，他顺着墙走了一段，感觉到床在身后。所以当他意识到床在身后时，他觉得任务完成了。他停止了摸索那面墙。
He just assumed that the wall continued for another eight feet or so. But it didn't continue. It stopped. And there was this alcove.
他只是想当然地认为那堵墙还延伸了大约八英尺。但它并没有延伸。它到头了。然后就是一个凹室。
And this is the problem. When you're blind, you just can't assume anything. And the problem is you get a picture in your mind and if you get it wrong, you just live inside the mistake.
这就是问题所在。当你失明时，你不能想当然。问题在于你脑海中形成了一幅画面，如果你弄错了，你就只能活在这个错误之中。
This kind of thing happens to him a lot. Way, way more than you would think.
这种事情在他身上经常发生。比你想象的要多得多。
Two weeks before our interview, he got lost in another hotel room, this one in Los Angeles. He couldn't find the door to get out of the room. He says that during the decade that he slowly went blind--
在我们采访的前两周，他在洛杉矶的另一家酒店房间里迷路了。他找不到离开房间的门。他说在他缓慢失明的那十年里——
It took me a long time to come to understand that blindness actually wasn't the main problem. The main problem was embarrassment. That I had to give myself over to the slapstick of things.
我花了很长时间才明白，失明其实不是主要问题。主要问题是尴尬。我不得不屈服于那些笨拙滑稽的事情。
To state the obvious, sometimes it is just a lot easier to see things. Clears a lot of things up. And today on our radio show, we have all kinds of stories of people trying to take things that are normally invisible to them and make them visible.
显而易见，有时能看见东西确实容易多了。能让很多事情变得清晰。今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有各种关于人们努力将通常对自己不可见的事物变为可见的故事。
I'm talking about unspoken feelings. I'm talking about people's secret lives. I'm talking, in a very literal way, about me and the other people doing stories on today's radio program. As people on the radio, usually we are invisible, but today we are bringing you excerpts from the show that we did on stage in front of people last week in New York City, and then beamed into movie theaters all across the United States and Canada and Australia.
我说的是无法言说的心情。我说的是人们的秘密生活。从字面意义上讲，我说的是我和其他在今天的广播节目中讲述故事的人。作为广播从业者，我们通常是不可见的，但今天我们要为你播放我们上周在纽约市观众面前表演的节目片段，然后通过卫星信号转播到美国、加拿大和澳大利亚各地的电影院。
Some of the stuff on that show-- in fact, a lot of the stuff on that show-- was way too visual to put on the radio. But the rest of the show consisted of these great stories from David Sedaris and David Rakoff, and Tig Notaro, and others. We have a really nice show for you today.
节目中的一些内容——事实上，节目中很大一部分内容——太视觉化了，不适合放在广播里。但节目的其余部分由大卫·塞达里斯、大卫·拉科夫、蒂格·诺塔洛等人的精彩故事组成。我们今天为您准备了一个非常棒的节目。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One: Does a bear hit in the woods? So let's go to the first story that I'm gonna play you from the cinema event that we did. The guy who you just heard, actually, Ryan Knighton. He has this story that is not about what is invisible to him, as somebody who can't see. It's about being invisible. Here he is, Ryan Knighton.
第一幕：熊在树林里会排泄吗？那么让我们开始播放我们举办的电影院活动中的第一个故事。你刚才听到的那个人，瑞安·奈顿。他有一个故事，不是关于作为一个看不见的人对他来说什么是不可见的。而是关于被隐形。他就是瑞安·奈顿。
I couldn't wait to tell my daughter that I'm a blind guy. And I'm not saying I was excited to tell her, I'm saying I couldn't wait to tell her in a way that she could actually grasp the basic concept of blindness. The trouble is, a two-year-old can't imagine what it's like to be another person, let alone imagine an entirely different physical reality like blindness.
我迫不及待地想告诉女儿我是一个盲人。我不是说我兴奋地告诉她，我是说我迫不及待地想以一种她能真正理解失明这个基本概念的方式告诉她。问题是，一个两岁的孩子无法想象成为另一个人是什么感觉，更不用说想象失明这样一种完全不同的身体现实了。
I'd say to her, "Papa sees what you see when you close your eyes, but mine are open." Which makes no sense. To anybody. So the miscommunications began to pile up between us.
我会对她说：“爸爸看到的是你闭上眼睛时看到的东西，但我的眼睛是睁着的。”这毫无意义。对任何人来说都是。所以我们之间的沟通误解开始堆积。
One day I'm standing in the hallway of our house and Tess either kicked or rolled this foam soccer ball to me. Foam soccer balls are really quiet. You see my problem.
有一天我站在家里的走廊上，泰丝把这个泡沫足球踢给我或者滚给我。泡沫足球真的很安静。你明白我的问题了吧。
And it rolled by, yes, and I ignored it. But I didn't know it was there. And she got upset. She wants to know why didn't I kick it back to her? Why didn't I want to play with her? And she began to cry.
它确实滚过去了，我没理会。但我不知道它在那里。她很难过。她想知道为什么我不把它踢回去？为什么我不想和她玩？她开始哭。
Now I don't know what's going on at all. So I'm just saying things like, "what's wrong, punkin?" And like, "hey, why don't you go get your ball or something?"
我完全不知道发生了什么。所以我只是说些类似“怎么了，宝贝？”还有“嘿，你为什么不去把球拿回来之类的？”
Yeah, my wife did see this happen later on. And only then did I learn how I was rejecting my kid all day. And part of me felt useless as a father. And another part of me just felt really angry at NERF.
是的，我妻子后来确实看到了这一幕。直到那时，我才知道自己整天都在拒绝我的孩子。我的一部分觉得自己作为一个父亲毫无用处。另一部分则对NERF（泡沫玩具厂商）感到非常生气。
Another time I picked up Tess at a daycare. And "Papa, Papa!" she screams as I walk in. And she sees me, and I squat down and I open my arms, and I wait for the hug. Because it's best that I wait, because the floor is dotted with babies between us. And nothing ruins our sweet moment like me stomping on babies.
还有一次我去托儿所接泰丝。我走进去时她尖叫着“爸爸，爸爸！”她看见我了，我蹲下来张开双臂，等待拥抱。因为最好还是等她过来，因为我们之间到处都是婴儿。没有什么比我踩到婴儿更能破坏我们甜蜜的时刻了。
So her body slams into mine and she wraps herself in a monkey hug, and I tell her how much I've missed her. And of course, to that, she cries. But she cried on the other side of the room.
于是她的身体撞进我怀里，紧紧抱着我，我告诉她我有多想她。当然，听到这儿她哭了。但她是在房间的另一头哭。
And suddenly, I feel this body and it's not familiar. And in fact, it's a little boy. And Tess is crying "Papa, Papa!" as if the word itself hurts, on the other side of the room. And so she just can't understand why I've hugged another child And I chase after the sound of her, and I'm sorry about the babies.
我突然感觉到一个身体，但很陌生。实际上，是一个小男孩。而泰丝在房间另一头哭喊着“爸爸，爸爸！”，仿佛这个词本身就很伤人。她无法理解为什么我拥抱了另一个孩子。我追着她的声音跑去，我很抱歉撞到了婴儿们。
So the miscommunications piled up, and they were mostly just little heartbreaks, but sometimes they were dangerous. There's times when I would walk her to the daycare in the morning. And I work at a university, and we'd walk across campus together in the morning. And she'd be in one of those NASCAR roll cage backpack things, which are great for blind fathers.
所以沟通误解越积越多，它们大多只是小小的伤心事，但有时却很危险。有时早上我会陪她去托儿所。我在大学工作，我们早上会一起穿过校园。她会坐在那种NASCAR防滚架式的背包里，这对盲人父亲来说很棒。
And we'd make our way across campus, and it's beautiful. It's in the mountains and it's forested. And I say this just so you can understand my legitimate panic when from her backpack she said to me one of her few words. She said "bear."
我们穿过校园，那里很美。它坐落在森林茂密的山区。我这么说只是为了让你理解我当时合法的恐慌，当她从背包里对我说出她为数不多的词汇之一时。她说“熊”。
And I froze.
我僵住了。
"What's that, punkin?"
“那是什么，宝贝？”
And I turned, 'cause I can still see some smears, so I looked for a big black one.
我转过身，因为我还能看到一些模糊的色块，所以我寻找一个巨大的黑色东西。
"Bear."
“熊。”
And I said, "There? Like we're going over there?"
我说：“在那儿？就像我们要去那边一样？”
And she's "bear, bear." And she's getting more upset, very clearly.
她说“熊，熊。”而且很明显，她越来越难过了。
Now this is Canada. We're in the forest. And this is the mountains, and the bears love our dumpsters. They dine frequently.
这可是加拿大。我们在森林里。这是山区，熊非常喜欢我们的垃圾桶。它们经常光顾。
The security guards just tell us which entrances and exits to avoid and they even just lock down the daycare and let the kids bust out the Goldfish crackers and watch the bears from the windows like some demented drive-in movie. And now Tess is watching one from the comfort of my back. And where it is I have no idea.
保安只会告诉我们避开哪些入口和出口，他们甚至会直接封锁托儿所，让孩子们拿出金鱼饼干，像看某种疯狂的汽车影院一样从窗户看熊。现在泰丝正舒服地坐在我的背上看着一只。而它到底在哪里我根本不知道。
Now I can feel she's upset and she's sort of leaning. So I reached behind me, and I grabbed her hand, and she was pointing right behind us.
现在我能感觉到她很难过，而且身体有点倾斜。所以我伸手到背后，抓住了她的手，她正指着我们身后。
So I reeled around to face the bear. And I smelled for it. And I have no idea what bear smell is.
于是我猛地转过身面对那只熊。我闻了闻它。我根本不知道熊是什么味道。
Now I didn't know if I should run, or if that would startle the bear to charge us. Or if I would just run into the bear, and that would be ironic. So I said, "let's just go this way, punkin." And I started to run, and she got really upset. So I said, "actually, let's go this way."
我不知道我是该跑，还是那会惊动熊向我们冲过来。或者如果我直接撞上熊，那会很讽刺。所以我说：“我们往这边走吧，宝贝。”我开始跑，她变得非常难过。我说：“其实，我们往这边走。”
And she got really upset. And I thought, well I'm running, I'm pinballing around this parking lot with a baby on my back like a Geiger counter.
她变得非常难过。我想，好吧，我背着个孩子在这个停车场里像盖革计数器一样乱撞。
And then it occurs to me. And I reach back with both hands, and yeah, she dropped her teddy bear. And yeah, she'd grown a little frustrated.
然后我意识到了。我用双手向后一摸，是的，她弄丢了她的泰迪熊。是的，她有点沮丧。
But everything changed when she was three. And I remember the exact moment. We were sitting in the kitchen and I asked her to pass me a cookie and she did. And I reached for it and did my usual dumb crab pinching the air thing.
但一切在她三岁时改变了。我记得那一刻。我们坐在厨房里，我让她给我递块饼干，她照做了。我伸手去拿，做了我那惯常的愚蠢的螃蟹夹空气动作。
And she said, "Papa doesn't see!" And I thought, that's what I've been saying!
她说：“爸爸看不见！”我心想，这不就是我一直说的吗！
And we said "Yes, Tess. Papa doesn't see." And then she had to check.
我们说“是的，泰丝。爸爸看不见。”然后她得核实一下。
"Mummy sees."
“妈妈能看见。”
And we said, "Yes, Mummy sees."
我们说：“是的，妈妈能看见。”
And she said, "Tess sees?"
她说：“泰丝能看见？”
And we said, "Yes, you see."
我们说：“是的，你能看见。”
And one week later, we were sitting in the living room, and she was watching Sesame Street or something. And she said, "Papa, who's that?" And I said, "Ah, Papa doesn't see."
一周后，我们坐在客厅里，她在看《芝麻街》之类的节目。她说：“爸爸，那是谁？”我说：“啊，爸爸看不见。”
And so she grabbed my hand and she put it on the screen, and she drew it over whatever she was looking at. Thank you.
于是她抓住我的手放在屏幕上，牵着它掠过她正在看的东西。谢谢。
Ryan Knighton. He's the author of the books C'mon Papa and Cockeyed.
瑞安·奈顿。他是《C'mon Papa》和《Cockeyed》的作者。
[MUSIC--"NEEDING/GETTING" BY OK GO]
[音乐--“NEEDING/GETTING” BY OK GO]
This, by the way, is the band OK Go, playing a song on hand bells with the audience. OK, back to the live show.
顺便说一句，这是OK Go乐队，正在和观众一起用手摇铃演奏歌曲。好了，回到现场表演。
Act Two: Groundhog Dayne.
第二幕：土拨鼠日戴恩。
I had the experience a couple years ago that a friend of mine became roommates with Bobby Kennedy's daughter, one of his daughters. And she's like, do you want to meet her? Do you want to meet her? She's really nice.
几年前我有过一次经历，我的一个朋友和鲍比·肯尼迪的女儿，他的一个女儿成了室友。她说，你想见她吗？你想见她吗？她人很好。
I was like, we're not supposed to meet the Kennedys! Like the Kennedys, that is too famous for us to meet. Like that's too famous for a normal person to meet. Do you know what I mean?
我说，我们不应该见肯尼迪家族！像肯尼迪一家，那对我们来说太出名了！对普通人来说太有名了。你知道我的意思吗？
The super famous are over there, and we are over here in our world. And we're not supposed to run into Angelina Jolie at the CVS, you know?
超级明星在那个世界，我们在这个世界。我们不应该在CVS药店偶遇安吉丽娜·朱莉，你懂吗？
But sometimes the iconic, the famous, the stars that we remember from when we were younger, they leave their magical, invisible world and actually tread in our world. And this was witnessed recently by comedian Tig Notaro. Welcome her.
但有时偶像、名人、我们年轻时记住的明星，他们会离开他们神奇而隐形的世界，踏入我们的世界。喜剧演员蒂格·诺塔洛最近就目睹了这一点。欢迎她。
So I live in Los Angeles. And I went to this party with my friend Pam. And we were going to leave the party and she said to me, "Do you know who that was standing by the door?"
我住在洛杉矶。我和朋友帕姆去参加了一个派对。我们正要离开时，她对我说：“你知道门口站着的那个人是谁吗？”
I said no.
我说不知道。
She said, "that was Taylor Dayne."
她说：“那是泰勒·戴恩。”
Do you know who Taylor Dayne is? No? She was a pop singer in the late '80s, early '90s. She sang "Love Will Lead You Back." She sang "Tell It to My Heart."
你知道泰勒·戴恩是谁吗？不知道？她是80年代末90年代初的流行歌手。她唱过《Love Will Lead You Back》。她唱过《Tell It to My Heart》。
Anyway, I love Taylor Dayne. And not ironically. I love Taylor Dayne.
不管怎样，我爱泰勒·戴恩。不是讽刺的那种。我爱泰勒·戴恩。
So I went back into the party, and I went up to her and I said, "Excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you. But I just have to tell you, I love your voice."
于是我回到派对上，走到她面前说：“不好意思，打扰一下。但我必须告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。”
And she just turned and said, "Yeah, I don't do that anymore."
她转过身说：“是吗，我不做那个了。”
And I looked over and this other friend of mine was doubled over laughing at me. She was like, "Yeah, you just got dissed by Taylor Dayne." Didn't feel great. So I left the party.
我看向旁边，我的另一个朋友笑得前仰后合。她说：“没错，你刚被泰勒·戴恩羞辱了。”感觉不太好。于是我离开了派对。
Then like nine months passed. And I happened to be out to eat with that same friend of mine, Pam. And there was a party of 10 seated right behind us. You guys are not going to believe who was sitting there. Any guesses?
然后过了大概九个月。我和那个朋友帕姆出去吃饭。我们身后的餐桌坐了10个人。你们绝对猜不到是谁坐在那里。有谁猜猜吗？
Andy Gibb?
安迪·吉布？
Just think about-- what's that?
就想一想——那是什么？
Taylor Dayne.
泰勒·戴恩。
That's correct. It was Taylor Dayne.
对了。就是泰勒·戴恩。
Pam said, "Oh my gosh, you have to say something to her."
帕姆说：“天哪，你必须跟她说点什么。”
And I said, "No question." 'Cause I still love Taylor Dayne.
我说：“没问题。”因为我仍然爱泰勒·戴恩。
But I didn't know what to say to her. And then I realized the best thing that I could say to Taylor Dayne would be the exact same sentence that I said the first time. So I turned around and I interrupted her entire dinner. And I said, "Excuse me, sorry to bother you. But I just have to tell you, I love your voice."
但我不知道该对她说什么。然后我意识到我能对泰勒·戴恩说的最好的一句话就是我第一次说的那句。于是我转过身，打断了她整顿晚餐。我说：“不好意思，抱歉打扰了。但我必须告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。”
And she said, "My speaking voice?"
她说：“我的说话声？”
And I said, "Yes. I was sitting here with my friend. I heard someone talking behind me, and I said, I need to turn around a compliment this person on their speaking voice."
我说：“是的。我正和我朋友坐在这里。我听到身后有人在说话，我就想，我得转过去夸夸这个人的声音。”
And what I didn't realize at the time was that Taylor Dayne was pursuing an acting career, which I guess is why she was no longer accepting compliments on her singing voice. Then like a year passed. And at this point, I've told all of my friends about my run-ins with Taylor Dayne, and how she's the easiest person in the world to run into. Like I'm not even convinced that she's not here tonight.
当时我没意识到的是，泰勒·戴恩正在追求演艺事业，我想这就是她不再接受关于歌唱声音夸奖的原因。然后又过了一年。此时，我已经告诉了所有的朋友关于我偶遇泰勒·戴恩的事，以及她是世界上最容易偶遇的人。我觉得她今晚甚至可能就在这儿。
So I was at my writing partner Kyle's house, and my phone rang and it was Sarah Silverman. And at the time, Sarah was dating Jimmy Kimmel. And Sarah called and said, "Guess who's promoting a new CD on Jimmy's show tomorrow night?" You guys will not believe who it was.
我当时在我的创作搭档凯尔家，我的电话响了，是莎拉·斯尔弗曼。当时莎拉在和吉米·坎摩尔约会。莎拉打电话说：“猜猜谁明晚要上吉米的节目宣传新唱片？”你们绝对猜不到是谁。
Taylor Dayne!
泰勒·戴恩！
Yes, it was Taylor Dayne. You're good with patterns.
没错，是泰勒·戴恩。你很会找规律。
Sarah said, "I want you to come down to Jimmy's show tomorrow night. And I want you to say those exact same words that you said the other times."
莎拉说：“我希望你明晚来吉米的节目。我希望你再说一遍你之前说的那几句话。”
And I said, "No question."
我说：“没问题。”
But I didn't end up having to go to Jimmy's show the next night, because that same day that Sarah called me at Kyle's house, Kyle and I took a lunch break. We ordered lunch to be picked up. We walked across the street to the strip mall where the restaurant was.
但我没能去吉米的节目，因为莎拉给凯尔家打电话的那天，凯尔和我也去吃了午饭。我们点餐外带。我们穿过马路来到餐馆所在的商业街。
Kyle was walking in front of me. I was walking behind him. We walked up to the restaurant, he opened the door, he looked at this table, then he looked back at me, then he looked back at the table. And I was like, "Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, of course she's here."
凯尔走在我前面。我在他后面。我们走进餐馆，他看了一眼餐桌，然后回头看我，又看向餐桌。我心想：“噢对，没错，她当然在这儿。”
And Kyle and I walked over to the counter where our food was waiting for us, and Kyle was just pacing back and forth, about to have a stroke. And I was like, "What is your problem?"
凯尔和我走向柜台取餐，凯尔来回踱步，快要气疯了。我问：“你怎么了？”
And he said, "Nothing, I'm just really uncomfortable right now."
他说：“没什么，我现在感觉很不自在。”
And I said, "Why?"
我问：“为什么？”
And he said, "Because I know it's about to happen."
他说：“因为我知道这就要发生了。”
And I said, "Yeah, and I can't wait to do it." I said, "This has nothing to do with you." I said, "This is between me and Taylor Dayne." I said, "but what I do need you to do when I go up and interrupt her lunch, I want you to take my cellphone, and just point it in the general vicinity and videotape me talking to Taylor Dayne. Just so I finally have proof."
我说：“没错，我迫不及待了。”我说：“这和你没关系。这是我和泰勒·戴恩之间的事。”我说：“但我需要你做的是，当我走过去打断她午餐时，你拿我的手机，对着那个大概方向把我和泰勒·戴恩说话的过程拍下来。这样我终于有证据了。”
And Kyle said, "OK."
凯尔说：“好吧。”
So I walked up to Taylor Dayne's table and I said, "Excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you. But I just have to tell you, I love your voice."
所以我走到泰勒·戴恩的桌子前说：“不好意思，抱歉打扰了。但我必须告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。”
And she said, "Thank you."
她说：“谢谢。”
And I was like, oh, that was weird. But the best part was when Kyle and I went back and looked at that video footage, you didn't hear me talking to Taylor Dayne. You just heard Kyle in an imaginary conversation going, "Oh hey. Hey man, what's going on? I'm having lunch at the Chicken Cafe, at the Pizza Cal, at the California Chicken Kitchen Pizza Kitchen Cafe."
我心想，哦，那挺怪的。但最棒的部分是当凯尔和我回去看视频录像时，你没听到我和泰勒·戴恩说话。你只听到凯尔在进行一段想象中的对话，说着：“噢嘿。嘿哥们，怎么了？我在Chicken Cafe吃午饭，在Pizza Cal，在加州Chicken Kitchen Pizza Kitchen Cafe。”
So the person that Kyle made up in that conversation was the world's most difficult human being that will not let the easy stuff slide. The person on the other end of that call is going, "Whoa, whoa, whoa. Back up, dude. Where are you having lunch? At the Chicken What Cafe? No man, I've never heard of that place. This conversation is going no further until you make it clear to me where exactly you're having lunch right now."
所以凯尔在那个对话中编造的那个人是世界上最难缠的人，绝不让简单的事情过去。电话那头的人说：“哇，哇，哇。等一下，伙计。你在哪儿吃午饭？在什么Chicken什么Cafe？不，伙计，我从没听说过那个地方。这段对话在你说清楚你现在到底在哪儿吃午饭之前不会再进行下去了。”
And I feel confident that I'm the reason that Taylor Dayne ended up putting out another record. 'Cause you know she called her manager and was like, "My fans miss me. They love me. I mean, sure they're a a bunch of he/she-looking robots."
我相信我就是泰勒·戴恩最终又出唱片的原因。因为你知道她肯定给经纪人打电话说：“我的粉丝想我了。他们爱我。我是说，当然，他们是一群长得像机器人的人。”
"Excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you. But I just have to tell you, I love your voice. Excuse me, I'm sorry to bother you. But I just have to tell you, I love your-- Excuse me."
“不好意思，抱歉打扰了。但我必须告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。不好意思，抱歉打扰了。但我必须告诉你，我喜欢你的——不好意思。”
Just as a side note, I left out other times that I ran into Taylor Dayne. Anyway, thank you.
作为一个旁注，我省略了其他几次我偶遇泰勒·戴恩的情况。总之，谢谢。
Tig Notaro! Tig Notaro! Her website, tignation.com. Her podcast, Professor Blastoff. Her newest CD, Good One.
蒂格·诺塔洛！蒂格·诺塔洛！她的网站tignation.com。她的播客Professor Blastoff。她的最新CD《Good One》。
And now ladies and gentlemen, please welcome Taylor Dayne.
现在女士们先生们，请欢迎泰勒·戴恩。
Oh yeah. Defiance!
噢耶。挑衅！
[MUSIC--"I'LL ALWAYS LOVE YOU" BY TAYLOR DAYNE]
[音乐--“I'LL ALWAYS LOVE YOU” BY TAYLOR DAYNE]
OK, this is me live in the studio. I should probably describe what is happening here.
好的，这是我在演播室现场。我应该描述一下这里正在发生什么。
Taylor Dayne, in a sequined mini-dress, is singing to Tig. Tig is sitting on this stool onstage, her arms are crossed, she's looking sort of skeptical. And Taylor's trying to win her over.
身穿亮片迷你裙的泰勒·戴恩正在为蒂格唱歌。蒂格坐在台上的高脚凳上，双臂交叉，表情看起来有点怀疑。泰勒正在努力赢得她的好感。
You know the words. I see you in diners. In coffee beans. My speaking voice.
你知道歌词的。我在餐馆里见到你。在咖啡豆里。我的说话声。
So it's around here in the song that Taylor does start to win Tig over.
所以在歌曲的这个阶段，泰勒确实开始赢得蒂格的好感了。
She's with me now. Show 'em what you got, Tig. Let's go.
她现在跟我在一起了。秀出你的本领，蒂格。来吧。
So Tig does some dance moves.
于是蒂格做了一些舞蹈动作。
Give it to 'em good.
好好给他们露一手。
They're laughing 'cause she busts out vintage Michael Jackson moves.
他们在大笑，因为她跳出了复古的迈克尔·杰克逊舞步。
You like that singing voice?
你喜欢那个唱歌的声音吗？
I love it.
我爱它。
I love you love my voice! Tig!
我爱你喜欢我的声音！蒂格！
Taylor! I love your voice.
泰勒！我爱你的声音。
Taylor Dayne!
泰勒·戴恩！
Thank you!
谢谢！
Taylor Dayne!
泰勒·戴恩！
Coming up, David Rakoff's seven step process for grating cheese, David Sedaris, and other highlights from the show that we did on stage and beamed into movie theaters last week. In a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，大卫·拉科夫的刨奶酪七步法，大卫·塞达里斯，以及我们上周在舞台上表演并转播到电影院的其他亮点。一会儿回来，芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today on our show, we're bringing you stories from the episode that we did on stage in New York at the Skirball Center for the Performing Arts last week, and beamed into movie theaters all over North America.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们的节目当然都会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各种故事。今天在我们的节目中，我们要为您带来上周在纽约斯基尔鲍尔表演艺术中心舞台上表演、并转播到北美各地电影院的一期节目。
As I said earlier, about half this show is just way too visual to ever put on the radio. It had dance and animation and all kinds of stuff. But half was a regular show like we always do. The theme was "The Invisible Made Visible."
正如我之前所说，这个节目大约有一半的内容太视觉化了，无法放在广播里。它有舞蹈、动画和各种东西。但有一半是像我们平时那样常规的节目。主题是“让隐形变得可见”。
One of the things that we have put up online that you can actually see right now for free, is a short film made by Mike Birbiglia for this show. It co-stars Terry Gross from NPR's Fresh Air, and it totally got huge laughs, totally killed in theaters. It is about what happens that you do not see when you listen to Fresh Air.
我们在网上发布的东西中，你可以现在免费看到的一项，是迈克·比比利亚为这个节目拍摄的一部短片。它由NPR《Fresh Air》节目的泰瑞·格罗斯联合主演，在电影院里引起了巨大的笑声，完全火了。它是关于当你听《Fresh Air》时，你看不到会发生什么。
You can find that on YouTube, just search there. Or go to our website, thisamericanlife.org, for the link.
你可以在YouTube上找到它，只要搜索一下。或者去我们的网站thisamericanlife.org获取链接。
We have arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three: Stiff as a board, light as a feather.
我们来到了节目的第三幕。第三幕：硬如木板，轻如羽毛。
In our bodies, blood moves, cells appear and cells die off, proteins form and are consumed, all invisibly to us. Until the moment that something goes wrong. And then we have no choice but to see the effects. The next story, from our live show, is from David Rakoff.
在我们的身体里，血液流动，细胞出现又消失，蛋白质形成又被消耗，这一切对我们来说都是隐形的。直到发生问题的时刻。然后我们就别无选择，只能面对后果。下一个故事，来自我们的现场秀，是大卫·拉科夫的。
It hardly merits the term dream, it's such a throwaway moment. But I've had it three times now. The dream, or dreamlet, goes like this. I say to an unidentified companion, "Hey, watch this."
这几乎称不上梦，只是一个微不足道的瞬间。但我已经做了三次了。这个梦，或者说小梦，是这样的。我对一个不知名的同伴说：“嘿，看这个。”
It's the punchline to that old joke, "what are an idiot's last words?" Except in my case, it is already too late. The idiot has already acted upon his idiot brag, the shallow part of the quarry has been dived into, the electric fence down by the rail yards unsuccessfully scaled, and my Trans Am has already failed to make it around Dead Man's Curve or down Killers Hill or off of, I don't know, Prom Night Suicide Cliff.
这是那个老笑话“白痴的临终遗言是什么？”的梗。但在我这儿，已经太晚了。那个白痴已经对自己愚蠢的炫耀付诸行动了，采石场浅水区已经跳了，通往铁路货场的电栅栏已经尝试攀爬过却失败了，而我的庞蒂亚克火鸟跑车已经没能绕过“死者弯道”或冲下“杀手坡”，或者坠下什么“舞会自杀崖”。
I had surgery last December-- my fourth in as many years-- to remove a tenacious and nasty tumor behind my left collarbone. I've also had radiation and about a year and a half's worth of chemo and counting. This last operation severed the nerves of my left arm, which relieved me of a great deal of pain. I'd spent three years prior to that popping enough Oxycontin to satisfy every man, woman, and child in Wasilla.
我去年十二月做了手术——这是四年来的第四次——切除左锁骨后方一个顽固而恶心的肿瘤。我还接受了放射治疗和一年半的化疗，而且还在继续。这次手术切断了我左臂的神经，减轻了我很多痛苦。在那之前的三年里，我服用的奥昔康定足以满足瓦西拉的每一个男人、女人和孩子。
But the surgery also left me with what's known as a flail limb. It is attached, but aside from being able to shrug Talmudically, I can neither move nor feel my left arm. It now hangs from my side heavy and insensate as a bag of oranges.
但这次手术也给我留下了一个所谓的“连枷肢”。它连在身上，但除了能像塔木德学者那样耸肩之外，我的左臂既不能动也没有感觉。它现在挂在我的身侧，像一袋橙子一样沉重而麻木。
But this is a dream after all. So "hey, watch this," I say. And up goes the left arm. The resurrection of the dead limb feels both utterly logical and completely magical. But it is precisely that magical feeling that lets me know immediately that I have moved in error, and the jig, as it always is, is soon to be up.
但毕竟这是个梦。所以我说“嘿，看这个”。然后左臂抬了起来。枯萎肢体的复活感觉既完全合乎逻辑又无比神奇。但正是那种神奇的感觉让我立即知道我犯了个错，而骗局，像往常一样，很快就会被揭穿。
I either literally pinch myself or snap my fingers in my ears trying to establish some reality. Or I ask someone, "is this real?" But I already know.
我要么真的掐自己，要么在耳边打响指，试图建立某种现实。或者我问别人，“这是真的吗？”但我已经知道了。
There are some questions in life, the very speaking of which are their own undoing. "Am I fired? Is this a date? Are you breaking up with me?" "Yes. No. Yes."
生活中有些问题，一说出口本身就是一种毁灭。“我被解雇了吗？这是约会吗？你要和我分手吗？”“是的。不。是的。”
The voice, my voice, that is asking "is this real" is the sound that is waking me up to the world where-- alas-- the dream's a total cliche. Anyone with one working limb would dream it, which frankly, yawn.
那个问“这是真的吗”的声音，我自己的声音，是把我唤醒到这个世界的声音——唉——梦境纯属老套。任何只有一个可用肢体的人都会做这个梦，老实说，真是无聊透顶。
The one difference I might point to is how I move in the dream. The limb floats up like a table at a seance. I am one of those empty windsock men outside of used car lots who suddenly billows up into three dimensional life. The arm rises and there at the top of my gesture, my fingers frill like a sea anemone caught by an unseen current.
我能指出的唯一区别是我在梦中如何移动。肢体像降神会上的桌子一样浮起来。我是那种二手车行外突然膨胀成三维生命的充气木偶人之一。手臂升起，在动作的最高处，我的手指像被某种看不见的洋流捕获的海葵一样颤动。
There is no functionality to it. I am not reaching for something, pulling the pin from a fire extinguisher, or hailing a cab. Mine is an extremely graceful and, I'll just say it, faggy gesture. Unmistakably, a gesture from ballet class, a gesture of someone who danced. Which is very different from having been a dancer.
它没有功能。我不是在拿东西，拔掉灭火器的插销，或者招手拦出租车。我的动作极其优雅，我就直说了，很“娘”。毫无疑问，这是舞蹈课上的姿势，是一个跳过舞的人的姿势。这和“曾经是一名舞者”有很大的不同。
I danced a lot, all through my childhood bedroom. It's an incredibly generic trait for a certain type of boy. Like a straight boy being obsessed with baseball, except it's better.
我童年时在卧室里跳过很多舞。这是某种男孩极其普通的特质。就像直男痴迷于棒球，只不过跳舞更好。
And after that, I danced fairly serious in university. But I was never really that great. And it's close to three decades ago now.
在那之后，我在大学里比较认真地跳过。但我从来没有那么出色。而且那已经是近三十年前的事了。
I took classes across the street at the women's college, not the most rigorous of places. And as a boy, one of at most any three males in any of the classes, the standards were even laxer. Any illusions I might have had about my scant abilities were blown to smithereens by the occasional class I took at a proper dance studio down on 55th Street in the real world, where actual New York City dancers came.
我在街对面的女子学院上课，那并不是什么严格的地方。作为一个男孩，在任何班级里最多三个男生之一，标准就更松了。关于我那点微薄能力的任何幻想，都被我在第55街真实世界的一家正规舞蹈工作室偶尔上的课给彻底粉碎了，那里有真正的纽约市舞者。
It was an exercise in humiliation and trying to make myself as invisible as possible. The only saving grace, indeed, the only reason I really went at all, were the 20 minutes in the men's changing room before and after. There's almost no way to explain it to a younger person, but you cannot imagine the rare thrill it was to see beautiful naked people in those pre-internet days of the early 1980s. I would walk slowly to the subway undone, clinging to the sides of buildings like someone who'd just come from the eye doctor.
那是一场屈辱的练习，我试图让自己尽可能隐形。唯一的安慰，实际上，我真正去的唯一原因，是课前和课后在男更衣室里的那20分钟。对年轻人几乎无法解释，但你无法想象在1980年代初那前互联网时代，看到美丽的裸体是多么难得的刺激。我会在出门时慢慢走到地铁站，像刚从眼科医生那儿出来一样紧贴着建筑物边缘。
If I retained anything from dancing, it's a physical precision that certainly helps in my new daily one-armed tasks. They're the same as my old two-armed chores. They're not epic or horrifying. Some of them don't even take much longer, but they're all to one degree or another, more annoying than they used to be, requiring planning, strategy, and a certain enhanced gracefulness.
如果说我从舞蹈中学到了什么，那就是一种身体的精确感，这无疑有助于我现在的单臂日常任务。它们和我的双臂家务一样。并不史诗也不恐怖。有些甚至不需要多花时间，但它们或多或少都比以前更烦人，需要规划、策略和某种增强的优雅感。
Oral hygiene. Hold the handle of the toothbrush between your teeth the way FDR or Burgess Meredith playing The Penguin bit down on their cigarette holders. Put the toothpaste on the brush, recap the tube, put it away. You really have to keep things tidy, because if they pile up, you'll just be in the soup. Then reverse the brush and put the bristles in your mouth, proceed.
口腔卫生。把牙刷柄含在牙齿之间，就像扮演企鹅人的富兰克林·罗斯福或伯吉斯·梅迪斯那样咬住他们的烟嘴。把牙膏挤在刷子上，盖好盖子，收好牙刷。你真的得保持整洁，因为如果堆积起来，你就会倒大霉。然后反转牙刷把刷毛放进嘴里，开始刷牙。
Washing your right arm. Soap up your right thigh in the shower, put your foot up on the edge of the tub, and then move your arm over your soapy lower limb back and forth like an old-timey barbershop razor strop.
洗右臂。在淋浴时把右大腿打上肥皂，把脚抬到浴缸边缘，然后把手臂在肥皂包裹的下肢上来回移动，就像旧式理发店的剃刀磨刀皮带一样。
Grating cheese. Get a pot with a looped handle, the heavier the better. This will anchor the bowl that you want the cheese to go into. Put the bowl into the pot.
刨奶酪。拿一个带圆环手柄的锅，越重越好。这会固定住你想盛奶酪的碗。把碗放进锅里。
Now take a wooden spoon and feed it through the handle of the grater and the loop of the pot, and then tuck the end down into the waistband of your jeans. Clean underpants are a good idea. Jam yourself up against the kitchen counter and go to town.
现在拿一把木勺，把它穿过刨丝器的手柄和锅的圆环，然后把末端塞进你的牛仔裤腰带里。穿干净的内裤是个好主意。把自己挤在厨房台面边，大干一场。
Special kitchen note: always, always, always have your bum hand safely out of the way, preferably in a sling since you now have a limb that you could literally-- no joke-- cook on the stove without even knowing it. Which makes me feel not like a freak, exactly, but well actually, like a freak.
厨房特别说明：一定要、一定要、一定要把你的废手安全地放好，最好用吊带托着，因为你现在有一条肢体可以在炉子上烤熟了却毫无知觉。这让我感觉不像怪胎，但也确实，像个怪胎。
At dinner with friends recently, the conversation turned to what about yourself was still in need of change? They all seem to feel that they were living half-lives.
最近和朋友聚餐时，话题转向了你身上还有什么需要改变的地方？他们似乎都觉得自己在过着半辈子。
One fellow hoped that he could be more like the god Pan, unabashedly lusty and embracing experience with gusto. Another wanted to feel less disengaged at key moments, able to feel more fully committedly human, and less like that old science fiction B movie trope: "What is this wetness on Triton 3000's face plate?" "Why, space robot, you're crying!"
一个人希望自己能更像潘神，无拘无束地沉溺欲望，带着热情拥抱生活。另一个人想在关键时刻减少抽离感，能够更完整、更投入地感受到自己是一个人类，而不是那个旧科幻B级片里的桥段：“翠顿3000号面罩上的液体是什么？”“哦，太空机器人，你在哭泣！”
We were going around the table, so the natural progression of things demanded that I eventually get a turn to weigh in as well. Suppose you're out to dinner with a group of triathletes, all discussing their training regimens. And you have no legs.
我们围着桌子聊，所以事情的自然进展要求我也最终轮到发表意见。假设你和一群铁人三项运动员一起吃饭，都在讨论他们的训练方案。而你没有腿。
They can't flat-out ignore you, and they also can't say words to the effect of, "well, we all know what your event is. Getting all that marvelous wonderful parking, you lucky thing!"
他们不能直接无视你，他们也不能说类似“好吧，我们都知道你的项目是什么。真是个幸运儿，能拿到那么多美妙极了的停车位！”之类的话。
It was uncomfortable, and I suspect more for me than for them. I have no idea. But thanks to my rapidly dividing cells, I no longer have that feeling-- although I remember it very well-- that if I just buckled down to the great work at hand, lived more authentically, stopped procrastinating, cut out sugar, then my best self was just there right around the corner.
那种感觉很不舒服，我想对我比对他们更不舒服。我不知道。但多亏了我那迅速分裂的细胞，我不再有那种感觉了——尽管我记得很清楚——那种如果我只是勤奋地完成当下的伟大工作，活得更真实，停止拖延，不吃糖，那么我最好的自己就在拐角处的感觉。
Yeah, no. I'm done with all that. I'm done with so many things.
是的，不。我受够了所有那些。我受够了太多事情。
Like dancing. I've no idea if I can do it anymore. I've been, frankly, too frightened and too embarrassed to try it, even alone in my apartment.
比如跳舞。我不知道我还能不能跳。老实说，我太害怕也太难为情了，连在公寓里独自尝试都不敢。
There was a time however-- as recently as about a couple of years ago, when I was already one course of radiation and two surgeries into all this nonsense-- when doing this simple barre exercises while holding onto a kitchen chair achieved what they always used to do. What they're supposed to do.
然而曾经有一段时间——就在大约几年前，当我已经在经历所有这些废话中的一轮放射治疗和两次手术时——当我抓着厨房的椅子练习简单的把杆练习时，它们实现了它们曾经一直做的事情。它们本该做的事情。
As best as I can describe it, it's the gestures themselves, their repetition, their slowness. It all hollows one out. One becomes a reed or a pipe, and the movement and the air pass through and you become this altered, humming, dare I say, beautiful working instrument of placement and form and concentration. But like I said, that's a long time ago. And a version of myself that has long since ceased to exist. Before I became such an observer-- I'm sorry.
我能描述的最好方式是，这是姿势本身，它们的重复，它们的缓慢。这一切都掏空了一个人。你变成了一根芦苇或一根管子，动作和空气穿过你，你变成了一个变了样的、嗡嗡作响的，我敢说，美丽的、能够发挥作用的方位、形式和专注力的乐器。但就像我说的，那是很久以前的事了。是我那早已不复存在的版本。在我变成这样一个观察者之前——我很抱歉。
So at this point, David Rakoff walks away from the microphone. And just when it seems like he might walk off stage, like he quit, he turns, and turns again. And then raises his right knee, and then places that foot down again, and then traces a half circle on the ground with his left foot. And then he lunges, he arches his back, swings his right arm in an arc from low to high, all totally graceful. And then, he dances.
就在这时，大卫·拉科夫走开了麦克风。正当他似乎要走下舞台时，像放弃了一样，他转过身，又转回来。然后抬起右膝，又把脚放下，用左脚在地上画了一个半圆。然后他冲刺，弓起背，右臂从低到高划出一道弧线，这一切都完全优雅。然后，他跳起舞来。
Look, mine is not a unique situation. Everybody loses ability-- everybody loses ability as they age. If you're lucky, this happens over the course of a few decades. If you're not--
听着，我的情况并不独特。每个人都会失去能力——每个人随着年龄增长都会失去能力。如果你幸运，这会发生在几十年的时间里。如果你不幸运——
But the story is essentially the same. You go along the road as time and the elements lay waste to your luggage, scattering the contents into the bushes. Until there you are, standing with a battered and empty suitcase that frankly, no one wants to look at anymore. It's just the way it is. But how lovely those moments were, gone now except occasionally in dreams, when one could still turn to someone and promise them something truly worth their while, just by saying "hey, watch this."
但故事本质上是一样的。你沿着路走，时间和大自然摧毁了你的行李，把里面的东西撒进灌木丛里。直到你站在那里，提着一个破旧而空空的行李箱，老实说，没有人想再看了。就是这样。但那些时刻是多么可爱，现在除了偶尔在梦中，当一个人还能转向某人并向他们承诺一些真正值得的东西时，只需说一句“嘿，看这个”，那些时刻就已经远去了。
David Rakoff is the author of many fine books, most recently Half Empty . This dance was choreographed by Monica Bill Barnes.
大卫·拉科夫是许多优秀书籍的作者，最近的一本是《Half Empty》。这段舞蹈由莫妮卡·比尔·巴恩斯编舞。
We have arrived at Act Four: Turn Around, Bright Eyes.
我们来到了第四幕：转过身，明亮的眼睛。
In his writing, David Sedaris can be kind of sharp tongued. But when you talk to him, when you meet him, he's really kind of a sweetheart.
在大卫·塞达里斯的笔下，他可能有点尖酸刻薄。但当你和他交谈，当你见到他时，他其实是个甜心。
When my sister Karen met him at a reading, I remember she said to David, she said, "You're a lot nicer than I thought you would be, based on your books." And I remember David said, "Oh, I'm not nice. Just two-faced."
我姐姐凯伦在一次朗读会上见到他时，我记得她对大卫说，她说：“你比我根据你的书想象的要好得多。”我记得大卫说：“噢，我不善良。只是两面派而已。”
So I'm pleased to say that tonight, you're really gonna see a story. You're gonna see David, how he really is tonight in real life, the real guy.
所以我很高兴地说，今晚，你真的会看到一个故事。你真的会看到大卫，今晚在现实生活中他真实的样子，那个真实的人。
And the story that he's telling is about feelings that often go unexpressed, at least unexpressed at the moment they happen. Welcome David Sedaris, please.
他讲述的故事是关于那些常常没能表达出来的感情，至少在发生的那一刻没表达出来。欢迎大卫·塞达里斯，请。
OK, an important fact about what the audience is seeing right here at this point in the show. David Sedaris takes the stage in full clown makeup. Red nose, white face, bald wig.
好的，关于观众在节目中这一刻所看到的东西的一个重要事实。大卫·塞达里斯全妆打扮成小丑上台。红鼻子，白脸，秃头假发。
To those who don't travel very often, the Courtyard Marriott might seem like a decent enough hotel. It's clean, sure. And the staff is polite. I wouldn't give you $0.02 for its pillows though, and the tubs are far too shallow for my taste.
对于那些不经常旅行的人来说，庭院万豪酒店可能看起来是一家还不错的酒店。当然，很干净。而且员工很有礼貌。不过我才不会花两分钱买他们的枕头，而且浴缸对我来说太浅了。
In the deserted lobby of the one I stayed at not long ago in New Hampshire, there was a coffee bar. Not a Starbucks, but a place that "proudly served Starbucks" and sold it alongside breakfast cereals and prepackaged sandwiches.
在我不久前住过的新罕布什尔州的那家酒店的空荡大堂里，有一个咖啡吧。不是星巴克，而是一个“自豪地供应星巴克”的地方，它和早餐麦片以及预包装三明治一起出售。
I noticed it on my way back from lunch, and just as I decided to get a cup of coffee, someone came around the corner and moved in ahead of me. I'd later learn that her name was Mrs. Dunstan, a towering, doe-colored, pyramid of a woman wearing oversized glasses and a short-sleeved linen blazer. Beside her was a man I guessed to be her husband. And after looking at the menu board, she turned to him.
我在吃完午饭回来的路上注意到了它，就在我决定买杯咖啡时，有人绕过拐角走到了我前面。后来我才知道她的名字叫邓斯坦太太，一个高大的、母鹿色的、金字塔般的女性，戴着超大的眼镜，穿着短袖亚麻西装外套。她旁边是一个我猜是她丈夫的男人。在看了菜单牌后，她转向他。
"A latte," she said, "now is that the thing that Barbara likes to get? The one with whipped cream or is that called something else?"
“拿铁，”她说，“那是芭芭拉喜欢喝的那种吗？带奶油的那个，还是叫别的什么名字？”
Oh [BEEP], I thought.
噢[哔]，我想。
"I can do a latte with whipped cream on top", the young woman behind the counter said. She was fair and wore her shoulder-length hair pushed behind her ears. Tiny moles were scattered like buckshot across her face, which was bare but for a bit of eyeliner. "I can do one with flavors too."
“我可以做一个加奶油的拿铁，”柜台后的年轻女性说。她皮肤白皙，肩长的头发别在耳后。小小的痣像霰弹一样散落在她的脸上，除了涂了一点眼线外，脸上没化什么妆。“我也可以加各种口味的。”
"Really?" Mrs. Dunstan said, "what sorts of flavors?"
“真的吗？”邓斯坦太太说，“什么口味？”
In the end, she settled on caramel. Then her husband squinted up at the board, deciding after a good long while that he'd try one of those mocha something or others, and could he get that iced?
最后，她选择了焦糖。然后她的丈夫眯着眼抬头看菜单牌，好一会儿才决定试一试那些摩卡什么什么的，而且能不能做成冰的？
As I groaned into my palm, he wandered off. His wife, meanwhile, leaned her bulk against the counter and began her genial interrogation. "Are you from this area?" she asked.
当我对着手掌叹气时，他走开了。与此同时，他的妻子把那臃肿的身体靠在柜台上，开始了她和蔼可亲的盘问。“你是本地人吗？”她问。
"No, from Vermont."
“不，从佛蒙特来的。”
"Well, that's interesting. What brought you here?"
“哦，那很有意思。什么把你带到这里来了？”
I learned that the coffee person used to work at the town's other hotel, which had recently closed for remodeling.
我得知那个咖啡吧的工作人员以前在镇上的另一家酒店工作，那家酒店最近为了装修关门了。
"So after it's done, will you stay put or go back over there?" Mrs. Dunstan asked. "Me, I have a son at the college, so that's what I'm doing. Just checking in. He's my second boy, actually. The first one went here too.
“所以装修完之后，你会留在那里还是回那边去？”邓斯坦太太问。“我呢，我有一个儿子在大学，所以我就是做这个的。只是来看看。其实他是我第二个儿子。第一个也在这里上的学。
"He's not working in his field yet, but with unemployment as high as it is, he should be lucky to have anything at all. If I've told him that once, I've told him 100 times. But of course, being young, he's impatient, which is natural. Wants to set the world on fire and if it can't happen by tomorrow morning at 9:00 AM, then life's just unfair and hardly worth living. What about you, did you go to college?"
“他还没在自己的领域工作，但现在失业率这么高，他能有份工作就该庆幸了。如果我对他说了那么一遍，我就对他说了100遍。但当然，年轻人嘛，没耐心，这很自然。想去大干一场，如果不能在明天早上9点前实现，那生活就不公平，甚至不值得活。那你呢，你上大学了吗？”
After what felt like weeks, the young woman finished with the orders. Two cups the size of waste paper baskets were placed upon the counter. And then Mr. Dunstan reappeared and pointed out the plate glass window toward a cluster of grim buildings on the other side of the parking lot.
在感觉像过了几周后，那个年轻女性处理完了订单。柜台上放了两杯垃圾桶那么大的杯子。然后邓斯坦先生重新出现，指着落地窗外停车场另一边的一群阴森的建筑。
"What are those?" he asked.
“那些是什么？”他问。
The young woman said they used to belong to the college. Of course, that was before they expanded the west side of the campus.
那个年轻女性说那些以前属于大学。当然，那是在他们扩建校园西区之前。
"And when was that?" Mr. Dunstan asked. He was a good 10 years older than his wife, mid-70s maybe, and he wore a baseball cap with a tattered brim.
“那是什么时候？”邓斯坦先生问。他比他妻子大整整10岁，可能七十岁出头，戴着一顶帽檐磨损的棒球帽。
"I beg your pardon?" the young woman said.
“你说什么？”那个年轻女性说。
"I said uh, when did they expand the west side of the campus? Was it recent, or did they do it a long time ago?"
“我说呃，他们什么时候扩建校园西区的？是最近，还是很久以前？”
Who the hell cares? I wanted to shout. What are you, the official historian of Who Gives a Damn College? Do you not notice that there's someone in line behind you? Someone who's been standing here, rocking back and forth on his heel for the last 10 minutes while you and that brontosaurus run your stupid mouths about nothing?
谁他妈在乎啊？我想大喊。你是什么？“谁在乎大学”的官方历史学家吗？你没注意到你后面有人排队吗？一个人在这儿站了10分钟，脚后跟不停地前后摇晃，而你和那个腕龙在那儿喋喋不休地谈论着毫无意义的事情？
I was this close to walking away, to marching off in a huff. But then Mrs. Dunstan would have turned to her husband and the girl behind the counter saying, "Some people!"
我差一点就要走开了，气呼呼地走掉。但那样的话邓斯坦太太会转过身对她丈夫和柜台后的女孩说：“这些人啊！”
I'd gotten a similar reaction the previous morning when I'd squeezed past a couple standing side by side on the moving walkway connecting concourses A and B. "In a great big hurry to meet that heart attack!" the man called after me. I wanted to remind him that this was an airport, and that some of us had a tight connection, if that was OK.
前一天早上我也遇到过类似的反应，当时我挤过了站在自动人行道上并排站着的一对夫妇。连接A和B航站楼的那种。“那么急着去见那场心脏病发作啊！”那个男人在我身后喊道。我想提醒他这里是机场，我们有些人要赶紧转机，如果没问题的话。
But of course, I had no connection. I just couldn't bear to see him and his wife standing side by side, blocking the way of someone who might have a tight connection.
但当然，我没有转机。我只是无法忍受他和妻子并排站着，挡住了可能要赶转机的人的路。
The Dunstans' bill came to $8, which everyone agreed was a lot to pay for two cups of coffee. But they were large ones, and this was a vacation. Sort of.
邓斯坦夫妇的账单是8美元，大家一致认为两杯咖啡花这么多钱确实很多。但它们是超大杯，而且这是度假。算是吧。
Not like a trip to Florida, but certainly couldn't do that at the drop of a hat. Especially with gas prices the way they are, and looking to go even higher.
不像去佛罗里达的那种旅行，但肯定不能说走就走。尤其是油价现在这个样子，而且还要继续涨。
While talking, Mrs. Dunstan rummaged through her tremendous purse. Her wallet was eventually located, but then it seemed that the register was locked, so the best solution was to put the coffees on her bill. That's how I discovered her name. And her room number.
说话间，邓斯坦太太翻遍了她巨大的钱包。钱包终于找到了，但收银机好像锁住了，所以最好的解决办法是把咖啡钱记在她的账上。我就是这样发现了她的名字。还有她的房间号。
My only question then was what time I should arrange her wake-up call for. Let's see how chatty you feel at 4:00 AM, I thought. Then it was all about returning the wallet to the purse and getting that all safely zipped up before picking her drink off the counter and starting in on her long goodbye.
我当时唯一的问题是我该给她的叫醒电话定在几点。我想看看你在凌晨4点还会不会觉得那么爱聊天，我想。然后一切就变成了把钱包放回手袋，在从柜台上拿起她的饮料并开始她漫长的告别之前把一切拉链拉好。
When the two of them finally lumbered off toward the elevator, I approached the counter, hoping the woman behind it would roll her eyes, acknowledging that something really needed to be done about people like the Dunstans. She didn't, though. So I decided I would hate her as much as I had hated them. When she told me that her little stand didn't serve regular brew coffee, I hated her even more.
当他们两个终于摇摇晃晃地走向电梯时，我走近柜台，希望那个柜台后的女人能翻个白眼，承认真的得对邓斯坦夫妇这样的人做点什么。但她没有。所以我决定要像讨厌他们一样讨厌她。当她告诉我她的小摊位不供应普通热咖啡时，我更讨厌她了。
"I can do you a nice cappuccino," she said. "Or an iced latte, maybe." This last word was delivered to my back as I stormed out the door.
“我可以给你做杯不错的卡布奇诺，”她说。“或者冰拿铁，也许。”当我想暴怒地冲出门口时，最后这个词是对着我的后背说的。
Then it was up the street and around the corner to a real coffee place. The pierced and tattooed staff members scowled at my approach, and I placed my order confident that they would hate the Dunstans as much, or possibly even more, than they already hated me.
然后我走上街，绕过拐角去了一家真正的咖啡店。穿刺纹身的工作人员在我走近时皱了皱眉头，我下达了订单，相信他们会像讨厌我一样，或者可能比讨厌我更讨厌邓斯坦夫妇。
David Sedaris. He's the author, most recently, of Squirrel Seeks Chipmunk: a Modest Bestiary. Again, OK Go.
大卫·塞达里斯。他是作家，最近的一本书是《Squirrel Seeks Chipmunk: a Modest Bestiary》。再次重申，OK Go。
[MUSIC--"DO WHAT YOU WANT" BY  OK GO]
[音乐--“DO WHAT YOU WANT” BY  OK GO]
Well, our program was produced today by Seth Lind and myself. Our live cinema event was directed by David Stern. Annette Jolles was the associate producer.
好了，我们的节目今天由塞斯·林德和我本人制作。我们的现场影院活动由大卫·斯特恩执导。安妮特·乔尔斯担任副制片人。
The entire crew here are incredible. They're like NASA scientists.
这里的整个团队都很不可思议。他们就像NASA的科学家一样。
The executive producers for cinema are Robert and Julie Borchard-Young. Lenny Laxer was the technical manager. Emily Condon was the associate producer for today's show. Miki Meek helped produce the show.
电影的执行制片人是罗伯特·博查德-杨和朱莉·博查德-杨。兰尼·拉瑟担任技术经理。艾米丽·康顿担任今天节目的副制片人。米基·米克协助制作了节目。
Today's show was recorded live at NYU's Skirball Center for the Performing Arts. Amy Coombs, technical director. Jason Adams, production manager.
今天的节目是在纽约大学斯基尔鲍尔表演艺术中心现场录制的。艾米·库姆斯，技术总监。杰森·亚当斯，制作经理。
Claire Keane coordinated all the illustrations and animations. She did the poster art, just incredible. Station outreach by Sean Nesbitt, Kathy Twist, Roger Gamal and Heidi Schultz.
克莱尔·基恩协调了所有的插图和动画。她做了海报艺术，简直太棒了。肖恩·内斯比特、凯西·特威斯特、罗杰·加马尔和海蒂·舒尔茨负责电台联络。
Thanks to the many, many public radio stations who participated and brought people out. Thanks to my wife Anaheed.
感谢参与并带来观众的许多、许多公共广播电台。感谢我的妻子阿娜希德。
Our staff, the greatest radio production staff ever. Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer, Julie Snyder.
我们的团队，有史以来最棒的广播制作团队。亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。我们的高级制片人，朱莉·斯奈德。
Production help, yeah, from Matt Kielty and Elna Baker. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website.
是的，制作帮助来自马特·凯尔蒂和埃尔娜·贝克。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨负责我们的网站。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International, WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行，我们老板托里·马拉蒂亚先生对我们的节目进行管理监督。
You know, how did I end up in this job? How did it happen? He came to me over and over, walked up to me in restaurants and on the street saying the same thing over and over again.
你知道，我是怎么走上这份工作的？是怎么发生的？他一遍又一遍地来找我，在餐馆里和街上走到我面前，一遍又一遍地重复同样的话。
Excuse me, sorry to bother you. But I just have to tell you, I love your voice.
不好意思，抱歉打扰了。但我必须告诉你，我喜欢你的声音。
You mean my speaking voice? I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
你是说我的说话声？我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。